[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 chaque année les
restos du cœur organisent une collecte
nationale le premier week-end du mois de
mars cette année elle se déroule donc
les trois quatre et cinq mars dans
plusieurs centres commerciaux
supermarchés et hypermarché des Yvelines
pour en parler je reçois Anne
Marie-Noëlle Franco responsable des
ressources bénévoles au Resto du Coeur
Yvelines et Philippe Saint-Martin
référent de la collecte nationale pour
les Restos du coeur des Yvelines bonjour
bonjour alors nous connaissons tous les
restos du coeur de près ou de loin vos
missions les plus connues sont celles de
collecter de la nourriture et des
produits d'hygiène pour les adultes et
les enfants quels sont vos autres
missions
je réponds
alors donc nos missions au resto du
coeur sont très étendues nous avons donc
de la distribution alimentaire mais nous
avons aussi de l'aide à la personne et à
cela nous avons aussi des chantiers
d'insertion et nous avons aussi ce qu'on
nous appelons les toits du cœur les
toits du coeur c'est un immeuble où nous
accueillons des familles en difficulté
et nous les aidons à monter leur dossier
tout le long pour arriver à un chez soi
si on peut dire à eux voilà les Restos
du Coeur fonctionne grâce aux nombreux
bénévoles qui s'activent chaque jour
pour donner de leur temps aux personnes
dans le besoin est-ce que vous êtes
actuellement justement la recherche de
bénévoles toujours
toujours c'est ce sera un refrain je
pense
éternel oui nous sommes toujours à la
recherche de bénévoles de bénévoles
réguliers alors c'est vrai que on
remercie beaucoup tous nos candidats
parce que nous en avons qui sont soit
des étudiants soit des personnes en
activité malheureusement il se propose
souvent le week-end or nous ne sommes
pas ouvert le week-end ou le soir nous
nos activités sont surtout en semaine et
dans la journée mais oui nous avons
toujours besoin de bénévoles alors
justement quels sont les missions des
bénévoles et surtout les compétences à
avoir lorsqu'on veut devenir bénévole je
dirais qu'il y a pas de compétences du
moment qu'on a du coeur un sourire et
une bonne volonté c'est tout voilà moi
je dis que c'est tout ce qu'il faut
après on a besoin c'est très très varié
de de personnes pour distribuer les
aliments bien entendu dans les centres
mais nous avons besoin aussi de
chauffeur pour
alimenter nos centres d'activités mais
nous avons besoin de personnes qui les
aident dans nos tout ce qui est activité
d'aide à la personne de donc de
recherche d'emploi cours de français
droit éventuellement accès à la justice
enfin voilà donc on a beaucoup beaucoup
besoin et je dirais que toute personne
qui qui se sont amen de venir au resto
du coeur on les accueille et après on
voit avec eux où ils peuvent aller et où
ils pourraient apporter le plus de bien
à nos personnes accueillies
mars 2023 les restos du cœur organisent
donc une nouvelle collecte nationale
comment cette collecte justement
s'organise-t-elle dans les Yvelines et
de combien de points de collecte
parlent-t-on environ alors dans les
Yvelines on parle de 60 points 67 points
de collecte 67 magasins qui participent
60 collectes des produits et puis dans
cette autre magasin il y a des collègues
un peu plus particulières que nous
parlons nous parlerons plus tard des
collègues des matérialisés notamment
voilà donc 60 ça représente à peu près
1000 entre 1000 et 1100 bénévoles dont
la moitié des bénévoles occasionnelles
ou un jour alors justement parmi les
lieux on va en donner qu'un léger
échantillon il y a donc le Monoprix aux
champs de Westfield au Chesnay il y a
Carrefour Montigny Carrefour Rambouillet
ou encore Leclerc au Bois d'Arcy quels
sont les produits justement les plus
demandés par les personnes accueillies
les produits dont nous avons besoin
principalement ce sont tout ce qui est
conserves conserve de poisson de légumes
les produits d'hygiène pour adultes les
savons les gels douches et aussi les
protections féminines
les compotes les fruits au sirop et puis
les produits d'hygiène pour les bébés
aussi les couches alors par contre le
lait on veut bien avoir du lait du lait
en poudre mais pas de lait liquide car
les dates de de conservation sont bien
trop trop courtes pour nous c'est ça
l'essentiel de toute façon c'est d'avoir
des dates de péremption longue c'est
super pour pour pouvoir justement gérer
aussi le temps entre donc le fait où on
vous donne finalement un produit et le
moment où vous allez le donner est-ce
que justement vous vous pouvez donner
une liste est-ce qu'il y a une liste
accessible pour les personnes qui
viennent dans les magasins qui viendront
faire leur course pour les aider alors
les bénévoles servent à ça puisque en
fait on a des Flyers qui seront
distribués aux personnes qui viendront
et les gens
diront aux gens quels sont les produits
que nous recherchons principalement
parce que effectivement on patte on
pense principalement aux patatori mais
tous les produits qu'on a cité c'est
super important pour nous de pouvoir les
récolter et des produits donc les
conserves etc c'est les produits de
longue de longue durée de conservation
voilà alors vous êtes également en
demande vous l'avez dit de produits
d'hygiène comme du savon des protections
hygiéniques ou encore des couches pour
bébé depuis quelques années vous mettez
d'ailleurs l'accent sur ses besoins
essentiels pour les pour les pour
l'hygiène pardon des personnes
accueillies et des bébés est-ce que vous
remarquez justement une hausse des dons
à ce niveau là ou est-ce qu'il y a
encore un petit effort à faire
finalement sur les dons de produits
d'hygiène il y a un effort à faire sur
les dons polygiène d'autant plus comme
l'a dit Marie-Noëlle que on a parmi les
accueillis de plus en plus de de famille
monoparentales avec des jeunes enfants
donc ça c'est un besoin que nous avons
et on a une augmentation des accueillis
qui font que même si on récolte ce type
de produit on en a besoin voilà
justement nous les produits d'hygiène on
les utilise un petit peu tous les jours
etc des personnes qui sont en difficulté
du coup mettre l'accent plus sur la
nourriture que sur des produits
d'hygiène c'est aussi pour ça qu'il faut
donner des produits d'hygiène pour faire
don de produits hygiène qu'est-ce que ça
leur permet justement à à eux comme par
exemple les recherches un emploi etc
est-ce que ça peut les aider justement
ces produits d'hygiène oui bien entendu
je pense que le plus important c'est
déjà l'estime de soi et donc des quand
on a les cimes de soi après on est armé
pour aller vers les autres donc
l'hygiène ça a son importance donc on
est bien physiquement je dirais il y a
pas de souci après voilà c'est l'estime
de soi qui est le plus important il faut
redonner confiance aux personnes parce
que on vient pas de gaieté cœur non plus
au Resto du Coeur donc sur ce ces
personnes là il faut les aider on est là
pour les aider nous on n'a pas les juger
donc sur ce voilà
malheureusement c'est vrai qu'avec la
crise il y a des choix qui sont faits
donc le choix bah c'est pour nourrir ses
enfants et puis se chauffer après
certains produits on les prend plus
alors il y a une nouveauté un récemment
vous avez mis en place la collecte
dématérialisée elle sera justement
effective dans certains magasins dans
certains points de collecte pour pour ce
week-end je le rappelle du 3 au 5 mars
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la collecte
de matérialisée qu'est-ce que ça
signifie alors la collecte de
bettallialisés s'offre se frotte dans
trois magasins principalement un
Viroflay au Chesnay et à Noisy-le-Roi
dans des Super U en fait je récolte pas
de produits on distribue des flyers sur
lesquels il y a trois coups de barre et
les ce qui permet aux personnes de
financer la collecte en choisissant de
scanner un code-barre qui correspond à
deux cinq ou dix euros cette somme est
en récoltée par le magasin et est mise à
notre disposition et nous on dépense cet
argent dans le magasin concerné en
achetant les produits que l'on veut au
ciel ça nous permet aussi nous d'adapter
les achats en fonction des besoins des
accueillis mais il y a un engagement
justement les largeurs récoltés sera de
toute façon en produits d'hygiène ou en
produits voilà pour pour se nourrir etc
c'est nous qui et donc l'année 2020 vous
l'avez dit a été marquée par l'inflation
et la hausse des prix est-ce qu'on peut
craindre justement une baisse des dons
pour cette nouvelle collecte nationale
ou est-ce que on peut garder espoir
quand même en la solidarité finalement
il faut toujours garder espoir je dirais
qu'il y a pas de petits dons tout donc à
son importance donc nous cette collecte
c'est aussi pour proposer une
alimentation variée et sur ce tout donc
à son importance et on espère on espère
toujours enfin on garde le sourire on
garde le sourire il faut il faut donc on
va on va essayer de synthétiser un pour
cette dernière minute finalement donc
pour donner rien de plus simple on
achète le produit que l'on veut qui est
mentionné dans une liste que vous
proposez justement aux citoyens l'entrée
du magasin et on le dépose dans un
caddie tenu par un ou plusieurs
bénévoles ou la deuxième option
finalement donc c'est la collecte
dématérialisée donc encore une fois
c'est avec le code barre on scanne le
code barre tout simplement qu'est-ce que
vous attendez vous personnellement de
cette collecte
il peut avoir plus d'informations sur
votre site ad78.res restos du cœur.org
et pour revoir ou réécouter cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre site et
notre application radio sensation